So, I've spent the last couple of years
transforming Block's 3,500-person
engineering org into an autonomous one.
And this is a challenge that most tech
companies are actively trying to solve
or will be in the very near future. So,
today I'll share our path to getting
there.
Our agentic coding journey started very
early. We were building Goose, our
internal coding agent, even before the
LLM supported tool calling. We worked
with Anthropic as design partners for
the initial release of MCP, and Goose
became the reference implementation for
the MCP client. So, internally, our most
curious engineers were some of the very
first in the industry to use these types
of coding agents.
After a couple of months, about 90% of
our engineers were now using tools like
Goose and Claude Code regularly to
generate code. So, on paper, it looked
like we were all in on AI.
But our CEO was convinced that
engineering wasn't using AI at all.
Like, they couldn't be, right? As far as
he was concerned, because we weren't
shipping any faster.
Well, I had the numbers, both the
metrics and the token bills. So, I knew
that engineering was, in fact, using AI,
but he was right. Features certainly
weren't making it to our customers any
faster. So, I began to dig into this a
bit.
I think of AI enablements in three
phases: experimentation, adoption, and
impact. I'd say that we surpassed the
experimentation phase as 90% of our
engineering org was using AI, but they
still were kind of using it inside of
their IDE, you know, asking questions or
writing boilerplate code. And I knew
that if we really wanted to see
impactful outcomes, then we needed a way
to integrate AI into how we built and
ship.
I spent the first half of 2025 leading
AI enablement for our entire company.
So, 12,000 employees across every
function, marketing, design, finance,
legal.
Now, our CTO tasked me with building an
agentic engineering org.
Okay, sure.
But, what does that actually mean?
There's no playbook for any of this
stuff, right? And I know because I went
looking at your blogs hoping that you
all had it all figured out. But, I only
saw a bunch of posts saying how you all
were making it up as you went along. So,
I did the same, right? In the simplest
of terms, I defined an agentic
engineering org as one where engineers
leverage AI agents as their primary
means of producing engineering outcomes.
So, that meant that our engineers needed
to treat agents as core members of their
engineering workflow. Not just using AI
to help them write code here and there,
but actually working with agents.
Decomposing problems, delegating work,
reviewing and verifying what was done.
And we wanted them directing the work as
their default way of operating. But, of
course, the vast majority of our
engineers were not here. So, to see
where we needed to go, I came up with
the maturity model.
This model measures the engineer's
relationship with AI agents. So, how
they think and delegate and orchestrate.
And while I had some form of this model
in Q3 of last year, Steve Yegge's
Gastown article helped me reorganize it
into a better model.
So, stage zero is where the engineer
doesn't use AI tools in their workflow
at all. Stage one,
they use AI to auto complete, but
they've never used it in agent mode,
maybe.
Uh stage two is where engineers are
chatting with agents, but not using it
to produce any PRs. Stage three,
engineers are delegating tasks to agents
and reviewing the output. Those at stage
four are running multiple agents in
parallel. And then stage five is that
final boss where engineers are
delegating complete tasks to agents and
the agent is able to produce shippable
results without the human necessarily
needing to guide it. So, I'd say by the
end of the first half, the bulk of our
engineers were between stages one and
two.
And I needed to get them to stage five.
Now, I wasn't quite sure how to get
3,500 engineers to that level,
especially when one, this is all highly
experimental, right? There's no
playbook, again, for any of this. Um
two, things were moving so fast
that what might be a best practice this
week could be outdated when a new tool
or a new model drops next week. And
honestly, this was leading to AI
fatigue.
And then three,
people were already feeling turned off
by the top-down pressure from leadership
to essentially AI or die.
So, I thought about the 1990 rule where
in digital communities about 1% create,
9% interact, and 90% passively consume.
And this maps almost perfectly to how
engineers adopt AI. So, you'll have a
small percentage that'll deep dive and
start creating agentic patterns and
discovering useful techniques for
working with agents. You'll have some
that might tweak the agent's MD file
here or there. But most people aren't
going to spend the extra cycles to
figure this stuff out. So, I realized
that if my AI strategy depends on every
individual leveling themselves up, I'm
never going to see that broad impact.
So, I leaned into this model. And I used
it to my advantage. Instead of focusing
on all 3,500 engineers, I decided to
focus on forming the 1%, the power
users, from our most critical teams.
So, I started an AI champions program
where I handpicked about 50 engineers
across the company who could pioneer
what a genetic engineering looks like
for their team. Now, this was not a call
for volunteers, all right? I needed to
be strategic about the selection. I
needed engineers who were willing to
dedicate at least 30% of their time to
investing in AI enablement. I needed
those who wouldn't be discouraged by the
non-deterministic nature of AI and give
up on it all when it didn't work out of
the box, which it often did not, right?
So, I spent the week talking to tech
leads and managers to find the 50
engineers who could represent our most
critical repositories.
Now, remember at this point, most of our
engineers were between stages one and
two where they're chatting with AI but
not really using it to produce PRs. So,
I wanted to get the AI champions to
stage three. This was about June 2025.
So, the models were decent enough to
write a feature for you, right? But
chances were pretty high that the code
wouldn't conform to your team's
conventions and standards. So,
developers didn't trust the agents
enough to delegate work to it yet. So,
the first area that we focused on was
making our repos AI ready.
My theory here was if I can get
engineers to embed AI directly into
their repos, then not only would the
agents perform better but the entire
team would benefit, not just the 1%.
And the repos are a central point of
reference for every engineer that's
contributing code.
So, to make their repos AI friendly,
they added assets like contacts and
rules files so that agents could
reliably understand and navigate the
code base as well as contribute to it.
Now, when building the AI champions, I
made sure that we have folks from every
corner of Block engineering: Square,
Cash App, Afterpay, Tidal, across
front end, back end, mobile, data,
infra, right? Um we covered repos of all
shapes and sizes, the nasty big legacy
massive mono repos, the smaller
services, mobile apps, right? And that
mix let us pressure test patterns across
very different engineering realities so
that we could quickly see what actually
scales.
As expected, mono repos came with their
own challenges. But my JVM devs were
already strong in inheritance patterns,
so we set shared contexts and rules at
the root, then layered more specific
ones at the service levels.
We also learned fast that what worked
for web didn't necessarily work for
mobile. So Android and iOS even needed
different approaches at times.
So instead of
forcing a one-size-fits-all solution,
each champion figured out what worked
for their repo, and then teams with
similar shapes and sizes naturally
converged on the same tools and
patterns. And honestly, engineers loved
this, right? We let them choose what
made sense for their repo instead of
pushing a top-down mandate on them.
So we ended up with a standard set of
components that would make a repo AI
friendly, but again, customized for each
team's needs. Some context files like
agents.md or claude.md to provide the
agent with repo guidance, rules files to
provide the agent with some guardrails,
repeatable workflows like slash commands
and later agent skills,
um an enabled AI code reviewer,
preferably with some instructions on
what matters and what it should review.
And then AI attribution on PRs.
So at this point, we've done a lot of
great work and technically, we do have
the agents writing PRs, but I had a
couple of concerns, right? Not many
outside of the AI champions had gotten
to this level where they were delegating
work to agents. And the idea is to have
the work of the 1% lift everyone up. So,
we weren't there yet.
And then even with the champions, they
were delegating, but they were still
kind of babysitting the process. So, I
wanted to explore if we could delegate
work to the agents in a more hands-off
approach and make it easier for others
outside of the champions program to do
so as well.
So, there's three common places where
engineers receive requirements for work.
Issue trackers like Jira or Linear,
GitHub issues, and informally in Slack.
I wanted to be able to delegate work to
the agents from any of these places. And
the champions implemented all three.
So, true story.
We were in Slack one day, an engineer
saw a bug with the product and wrote,
you know, like, "Hey, I saw this bug.
Anybody else seen it?" So, engineer two
responds to that and goes, "Mhm, no, I
hadn't seen that one." Engineer three
@goose right there in Slack and says,
"Hey goose, have you seen this bug
before? Like, can you can you go and
check if this is a bug?" So, goose goes
to the repo, it like pulls the files
down, and says, "Yeah, this is a bug.
Here it is right here. But, here's also
three options of how you might implement
a solution, right?"
Right there in Slack, code snippets. And
so, engineer one goes, "I like option
one." Engineer two goes, "Yeah, yeah, me
too." So, engineer three says, "Hey
goose, go implement option one." Goose
does so, returns with a link to the PR,
right? So, the entire cycle from
discussion, diagnosis, issue creation,
alignment, and the fix took like 5
minutes all right there in Slack. Very
cool party trick, by the way.
Um engineers were also able to assign
linear and Jira tickets, as well as
GitHub issues to an agent, and have the
agent implement the work end to end. So,
now the agents have become a part of the
sprint. This blew everyone's minds. The
first time we did this, the team ran out
of work and had to pull in more tickets
like twice, right? So, of course,
engineering managers, product teams,
they love this flow. And the beauty
about these flows is that
all engineers didn't necessarily have to
learn a new skill. The champions had
already laid the foundation so that
agents were able to work well within
these repos, and they worked well all of
this worked well because it made
delegation feel native to how people
already work.
So, now I felt comfortable claiming that
we were truly delegating work to the
agents.
At this point, it had been 3 months
since launching the champions program,
and we were seeing great results.
AI-authored code was up by 69% reported
time savings increased 37%, and
automated PRs increased 21 times.
We were ready to pursue stage four,
multi-agent parallelism.
And with our setup, honestly, moving to
stage four was almost free. We were
pretty good at delegating work to the
agents now. But, this stage introduced
several new challenges that we needed to
solve. Engineers are now tripling,
quadrupling the number of PRs that
they're producing, but
the PRs are stuck waiting for code
reviews, right? So,
people struggled to stay on top of code
reviews even before we added AI to the
mix, so you know that it's bad now. And
I'll be honest, this isn't a totally
solved problem, but I'll share how we
did stop the bleeding a bit.
We absolutely had to get the bots to
help us review PRs. So, earlier in the
process, this was optional. Mostly
because the AI code reviewers sucked so
badly, and we were just pissing the
engineers off by having them use them.
But now, with the repo readiness work
that the champions had done, coupled
with better models and tools, shout out
to Codex, uh we were getting much better
results here. So, we enabled Codex on
all the repos, and we also created an
auto-fix loop where if Codex identified
issues, another agent will automatically
fix those issues and commit them to the
PR. So, now, at least people would no
longer complain about not wanting to
review sloppy PRs from bots, right? By
time they got to them, they were in
pretty good shape.
Another issue, specifically when running
multiple agents in parallel, was that
the agents were bumping into each other
as they were trying to work. And
more importantly, our machines couldn't
handle the load anymore. Like,
engineers' laptops were running out of
memory.
CPU was choking, you know? So, we
invested in dedicated cloud workspaces
where each agent ran in its own isolated
environment. And this allowed us to
easily run them in parallel and from
anywhere.
So, at this point, the engineers are
cooking. They got four or five agents
running at any given time, and that
number is growing. So, a small group of
engineers, including many of the AI
champions, started building our own
orchestrator to coordinate all of these
agents, Builder Bot.
And we needed Builder Bot to get us to
an autonomous engineering org.
We realized that if we're trying to
build anything close to an autonomous
engineering org, the agents need to
understand where everything lives and
what depends on what. So, we built a
company world modeled based on the
entirety of our
25,000
repo code base, right? And this was a
machine-readable view of every single
service and how they all connect.
And this allowed orchestrators and the
agents that they delegated to to pull
context in as needed and understand the
landscape as they implement.
And this enabled multiple agents to
explore different parts of the system in
parallel, each building their own
understanding and then come back
together and have the orchestrator put
all of this together, right? Put in a
plan that spans across multiple code
bases, which was especially useful for
us as we were building offerings that
spanned multiple products.
Now, with this, we had successfully
reached stage five, where engineers are
delegating complete tasks to agents. The
agents are able to produce shippable
results without human hand-holding. In
fact, this wasn't even limited to
engineers anymore. Anyone at the company
could act Build-A-Bot in Slack and have
it fix a bug or implement a new feature.
They didn't even need GitHub.
This felt like a dream.
Until it became a nightmare.
You know, of course, all layoffs are
tough, but this one felt different.
I had so many questions.
Was this my fault?
Did enabling employees to do the most
incredible work of their careers
ultimately result in their dismissal?
Just the day before I had felt so proud.
I was in awe of the way we were working,
feeling quite accomplished that I
successfully built an autonomous
engineering
But to what end?
I guess I'll leave you all with a few
questions.
What are we doing?
Where are we heading?
You know, we sure
that it's where we want to end up?